eric je sais que tu as été très peiné
par ce qui s'est passé hier est parce
que je viens d'entendre bah dites nous
justement ils entendent ce soir moi
c'est une mascarade l'a dit nous vous
redonner encore la parole à bela tarr
vous les normes nouvelles contrevérités
pour de nouveau ensemble moi je suis
venu dire des choses très simples
chanter lecture est évidemment par ce
qui s'est passé hier pas seulement mon
cas personnel mais par la tournure du
débat en général et je suis déterminé à
rappeler quelque chose très simple j'ai
fêté cette année mais 60 ans je mets au
défi quiconque de trouver un propos ou
un acte nous marrante un facho c'est
quand même la discussion d'hier ce qui
m'a été balancé à la gueule plusieurs
fois je défie quiconque de trouver le
moins
il ya quand même des doutes sur les
réseaux sociaux mais la terre bela tarr
qui s'est fait une spécialité de remuer
la merde remué la mer sur les réseaux
sociaux mais quand ça les arrange quand
ça n'arrange pas ils trouvent que les
réseaux sociaux vont trop loin
deuxièmement je ne me laisserai jamais
diffamé insulté et menacé j'insiste sur
ce ver menacé par un voyou car belattar
est pour moi un voyou avant tout en plus
d'être un humoriste pas drôle parce
qu'il a choisi ce créneau troisièmement
je rappelle ici que je suis le
représentant
peut-être minoritaire en ce moment à
gauche d'une gauche laïque laïque six a
dit quelque chose à bela tarr
républicaine et anti totalitaire ça fait
deux mois pour les crypto islamistes
comme belattar un fasciste parce qu'ils
aiment pas ils n'aiment pas la gauche
que je représente
et comme ils ne savent pas quoi répondre
il ya cette étiquette fachos qui me
colle sur le fond parce que c'est
beaucoup plus simple ce que j'ai vu hier
ce que j'ai entendu avec bela tarr dans
les dernières minutes du débat qui se
tourne vers moi avec un air menaçant et
qui dit ceux qui ont participé à
l'ascension des mots il faudra qu'il le
paye qu'est ce que je dois faire engager
une protection policière vous savez
comment ça se termine les menaces comme
ça non mais je vais pas citer des grands
noms vous savez comment ça peut se
terminer ça peut se terminer très mal il
m'a à nouveau menacé après l'émission au
moment de partir dans des termes non
ambiguë j'appelle ça un voyou et vous
lui redonner la parole pendant une
demi-heure ou ruy des caisses caf achour
naulleau il est incapable de sortir le
moindre événement phare de cette
mascarade non non non moi soit pas pour
ça et je suis venu eric eric eric avec
la rx et d'en rajouter dernière il est
maintenant que hier hier il a rendu le
plus grand service possible au
rassemblement national et à jordan
bardella parce que tout le monde à
trouver bardella en tout cas beaucoup
plus raisonnable que belattar non non ce
n'était pas le but d'un média il n'y a
aucune mascarade eric zemmour ici on
écoute tout le monde donc voilà c'est
normal on a donné la parole à tout le
monde yassine belattar il a fait une
annonce hier comme quoi il avait spolié
se présenter devant eric zemmour c'est
pour ça qu'on a invité ils ont parlé
encore ce matin chez jean marc morandini
sur ses news donc voilà on l'a invité
pour ça et forcément on est revenue sur
la sphère d'hier soir il ya aucune
mascarade ici on écoute les deux camps
et je vous dis on essaie d'être le plus
impartiale possible comme vous le savez
ici autour de la table eric naulleau a
été blessé hier par les propos de yacine
on peut on peut le comprendre et
forcément on comprend tous et c'est vrai
qu'un art voilà qui ont été blessés ça
s'est senti mentalement oui non mais
alors c'est pas moi c'est parce que je
suis écoeuré je suis écoeuré que nous
donne la parole à cet individu que je
trouve très dangereux et pouvoir je n'ai
jamais d'être avec les fascistes lui il
a défilé avec les islamistes on n'est
pas sur un pied d'égalité je ne suis pas
blessé parce que mon petit coeur
sensible saigne je suis blessé
démocratiquement parce que qu'est-ce que
vous et à y répondre c'est qu'il faut
pas laisser la parole à yassine belattar
voilà alors moi je suis pas d'accord
avec vous oui je vais rire et que je
pense éric
qu'il faut dialoguer avec tout le monde
y compris avec yacine moi la première
prise de parole avec la synth a été on
s'est engueulés sur ce plateau de mal
parce qu'il ya deux ans de ça ou trois
ans de ça je ne sais plus parce que
justement je lui reprochais l'ambiguïté
et le double langage mais je pense que
effectivement si on dit dès le départ tu
n'es pas légitime pour venir sur ce
plateau parce que je ne cautionne pas
tes idées parce que tu est ambigu il ya
plus de 10 ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé exactement 10 avec ses semblables
c'est ce qu'on a fait nous avec les six
victoires ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé hier soir je voulais bien
dialoguer il assortit cette carte de
fachos il a commencé à me menacer qui
est-ce qui refuse le débat jusqu'à
présent jusqu'à cette sortie ont
dialogué évidemment que j'ai pas défendu
bardella ou est ce qu'il a vu que j'ai
défendue bardella moi j'ai combattu le
fn et le rn toute ma vie voterai jamais
posé à protéger même je suis même
déclaré en faveur de la dissolution de
génération identitaire c'est quand même
bizarre pour un crypto facho je vais
vous dire hier voilà moi moi moi je vous
le dit hier je trouve que voilà vous
avez été ça a été trop loin parce que
ses conditions dans une discussion il y
avait lors d'anbar des là et je trouve
que c'est peut être parce que voilà il a
fait l'émission était vraiment top quand
on était sur le débat des trucs ici sont
nés dans un débat d'idées quand on part
dans les insultes etc c'est parce qu'on
veut ni dans touche pas à mon poste ni
dans btp et eric patrick
gille entièrement d'accord avec vous il
faut pas que les quelques mots masquer
le vrai grand intérêt du débat d'hier
nation voilà après eric je vais vous
parler très sincèrement la manière dont
vous agresser verbalement la yassine
belattar qui n'est pas là voyous crypto
islamistes c'est hyper violent et ben
c'est hyper violent et moi c'est ce que
représente benatar qui me paraît violent
plus que mes mots ma faim bon mois
chacun chacun sa sensibilité moi je veux
finir et je trouve que parfois dans le
débat ou dans le non débat vous avez un
côté j'impose mes idées je n'écoute pas
belattar n'a que le droit de se taire
parce que et c'est un islamiste bassij
pas ce qui s'est passé là bas si vous
n'êtes pas ce qui s'est passé hier vous
digéré que c'était l'élément de débats
quand belattar me dit de toute façon tu
vas te barrer comme un lâche le couloir
me suis dit ah bon tu as cucq et c'est
un élément de débat ça c'est un élément
dit dsk est ce que ça fait partie du
débat démocratique c'est de la
provocation de petits mais là on me le
demande et si m'exprimer mais non
excusez moi mais vous laisser et non les
autres laissent vous raconter n'importe
quoi je vous convient c'est parce qu'il
s'est réveillé et qu'est-ce que quel
message voulez faire passer soit voilà
si vous avez un dernier messieurs que le
débat était absolument indigne
simplement parce que belattar n'est pas
favorable au débat bela tarr est
favorable à la provocation il m'a dit
femme est ce que ce mot de fachos est
absolument insupportable et il m'a
menacée il m'a menacé sur le plateau et
en dehors du plateau gilles verdez quand
je me pose à des menaces qui sont faites
à mon encontre je regrette c'est pas moi
qui refuse le débat c'est simplement que
les termes du débat ne me conviennent
pas parce que la menace que fait pas
partie du débat voilà merci eric
naulleau match au yankee chant petit peu
triste parce que c'est vrai que là tout
se passe bien on est tous très très
potes on va pas se mentir dans l'équipe
et c'est ça que j'aime moi dans l'équipe
c'est que quand on est dans les
coulisses autant mathieu que yacine que
valérie que benjamin guillaume voilà on
est tous d'horizons complètement
différent bernard montiel même qui est
extrêmement riche
on est en écoute sur extrêmement non
mais on est tous extrêmement amis et je
vous dirai c'est vrai que sur le plateau
je vous dis ça change rien on peut avoir
des discussions mais après dans les
coulisses on est toujours très très
potes et c'est vrai que c'est une
famille incroyable donc voilà je vous le
dis et c'est ça qui changera jamais
j'espère que c'est ça qui changera
jamais j'attends mes émissions la
famille et dans tpm paix et aidants btp
puisque en tout cas tonga dans tpm paix
c'est vrai qu'on a une famille et dont
btp aussi serré qu'on se marre avant
même si on a des opinions très très
diverse voilà le sait que raquel garrido
et laurence haye et sont très très
copines même si elle vous entendez bien
n'exagérons pas
d'affairé il faut que vous soyez un
petit peu moins dur avec laquelle elle
est très sympa merci en tout cas et rien
n'est que témoin moi je regrette que ce
soit une demi-heure pour belattar et
cinq minutes pour moi voilà je n'en ai
maintenant mais je trouve que ça
prolonge le scandale dsk
mais non ça n'a rien à voir mais tout ça
n'est pas moi je voulais tu dise un mot
ce soir je voulais pas on n'est pas dans
un débat avec temple est juste que tu
sois dans un témoignage ou ça rien à
faire avec avec yacine la fin juin elle
de bagnères pour cette raison là
pourquoi parce que je voulais que chacun
se fasse une idée sur le débat on dit
mais bien parce que tu pourras exposés
oui mais je voulais pas faire un débat
totalitaire un témoignage est invité et
il en profite pour remettre une couche
de calomnie et de la contradiction je
trouve ça anormal et je trouve un
contrat d'une année battre a dit le
manceau non la mesure est pas la
dangerosité de ce sinistre personnage
qui est bela tarr je pense que vous ne
mesurez pas ce qui s'est fait hier avec
un type qui me menace et dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre vous savez où
peuvent mener les menaces qu'on verra
bien on verra bien non mais mais si les
leaders religieux il m'arrivera qu'elle
est
je voudrais c'est pratiquement aussi
aussi long que yacine donc arrêté avec
sa femme